[Musique]
qui était vraiment Louis XV un passionné
de sciences et de botanique un roi
discret un homme ou multiple conquêtes
pour fêter le tri centenaire de son
couronnement le château de Versailles
mais à l'honneur ce roi méconnu arrière
petit-fils du roi soleil
[Musique]
on l'amenait jusqu'à être appelé le roi
bien-aimé mais à la fin de soirée la
situation n'était plus les mêmes les
dernières années de sa vie ont été
beaucoup plus sombres Madame de
Pompadour l'extraordinaire pendule de
passement les souper aux cabinet le roi
et la chasse l'exposition propose une
approche plus intimiste de Louis XV où
l'exercice du pouvoir était passé au
profit de sa personnalité cette
expression est consacrée est divisée en
trois parties principales une partie
consacrée à l'enfance l'éducation
l'entourage familial ou non familial de
Louis XV une deuxième partie plutôt
consacré aux passions du roi et une
troisième partie plutôt consacrée aux
arts autour de Louis XV la partie qui
est consacrée à la chasse dans cette
exposition se traduit avec l'accrochage
de tableaux qui ont tous figuré dans les
appartements locales les tableaux de la
salle à manger choisi de gigantesque
tableau de bachelier représentant la
chasse aux urssa l'ours 400 œuvres
provenant de différents musées
France de collection
s posées certaines n'ont jamais été
présentées auparavant on peut également
y découvrir le style rocaille appelé
style Louis XV typique de l'époque comme
cette commode du roi cette commode qui
est un meuble mythique qui est un
chef-d'oeuvre de la rocaille qui a été
dessiné par ou imaginer par deux frères
en nomadisme les frères slot c'est un
meuble qui était dans une chambre royale
et on s'aperçoit que c'est un meuble
avec deux portes latérales de vantaux
latéraux et manifestement c'est
ventolatéraux servait au barbier à
mettre le matériel nécessaire pour la
toilette du roi le matin le parcours
offre également la possibilité de
visiter quelques-uns des lieux les plus
emblématiques du château l'appartement
de la marquise de Pompadour les
appartements du dauphin ou encore la
chambre de madame du Barry dernière
favorite du roi une exposition à
découvrir jusqu'au 19 février 2023
[Musique]